well four months at Oprah Winfrey
presidential run was just idle
speculation now it feels almost
inevitable thanks to Donald Trump the
age of the celebrity politician may be
upon us and stay here mark Stein is an
author and columnist he joins us tonight
mark I want to be clear at the outset
and on the record that I'm not in any
way criticizing Oprah I think it's a
federal crime and I pledge never to
criticize Oprah in any way and so I'm
not doing that now but I'm wondering
what you made of the reaction to Oprah
Winfrey last night where you had people
even Republicans purportedly Bill
Kristol jumping in and saying run Oprah
what what is that well I think Bill
Kristol if you recall his tweet from a
couple of months ago saying how much he
supports the deep State against Trump I
think we should draw from Bill Kristol
support of Oprah's candidacy that she
has been an agent of the deep state for
many years and that's why Bill Kristol
supporter what surprised me given the
control she seems to have over people's
minds is I mean I think we're both
assuming that if she ran the Democratic
primaries she'd get the nomination right
absolutely because look you have to
figure out and Wendy acknowledged this
in a certain sense if you're the
Democrats you want to try and drag Bill
DeBlasio or Elizabeth Warren or Bernie
over the finish line or do you just want
to cut to the chase and go with Oprah
and they're betting that if it's Trump
versus Oprah he's not going to be able
to do to her what he did to Jeb and
Hillary and she and and in a sense
that's valid she she was by far the
least idiotic person at that award
ceremony last night I mean she was
crafty and cunning in the way she tied
her personal story to this me to
business you know I mean which which i
think is actually one of the interesting
things about it
you know to me that ceremony was
ludicrous I felt for Rose McGowan and
Rosanna Arquette and Mira Sorvino as I
felt for the girls in Rotherham England
I spoke to who'd been
sexually abused by these Muslim grooming
gangs and then watched as all these
opportunist activists and politicians
turned the scandal into a way to advance
themselves up the greasy pole and the
victims were ignored and that's exactly
what happened last night
Mira and Rosana and Rose McGowan didn't
get any invites to the Golden Globes and
instead all these ridiculous a-listers
like Meryl Streep came along and said
well I'm going to show how much I
support defenseless women by only
wearing black so I've ordered my
couturier to dress me like Audrey
Hepburn in Breakfast at Tiffany's
that'll show him and I was completely
preposterous Oprah Oprah actually took
Oprah who was more opportunists than any
of them actually sees that issue and and
appropriated it to herself which I'd be
annoyed about if I were Mira Sorvino but
she did it at a skill level that's way
beyond Nicole Kidman or Meryl Streep or
any of those other ladies no no she's
talented there's no question about it
and and she certainly is a brilliant
communicator someone said to me though
recently who someone who shall remain
nameless because he doesn't mean charged
with a crime either I said you know I
respect Oprah but sometimes there is
this man said to me I feel like she
doesn't like me you know it's right
doesn't like me you think that's I think
a lot of people feel that way or what
percentage of the population feels like
Oprah's on their side well the question
is whether Oprah's is on her side I mean
she gave a rather curious interview I
think it was to the BBC a couple of
years ago where she said that really
just old white people need to die I mean
there is a and this is where it gets to
Wendy's thing about how she heals us all
and she brings us all together and I'm
not actually sure at this stage that
that talking about Sidney Poitier and
Rosa Parks does do that I mean for start
I'm not sure it's anything to do with
the challenges we face today not just
because America has elected a black
president and the Golden Globes is full
of famous and prominent black
celebrities and in
a biracial American woman is about to
marry into the royal family in a couple
of months so it's just not it's not just
that her parents didn't have a thing
about race but Her Majesty the Queen is
to approve every royal marriage doesn't
either and so there was something
slightly weird in her attempt which
which I was effective with the crowd in
trying to connect all these kind of
traditional racial tropes to the me
toothless let's let's not forget by the
way that all these feel-good movies
she's made like the butler that were
distributed by Harvey Weinstein
Harvey Weinstein wanted a piece of all
those affirmative action feel-good
booster ish movies because it was a
great way to get chicks liberal chicks
to go up to your hotel room there are
all kinds of contradictions that play in
in in in the past she's trying to go and
negotiate everything's more complicated
than it looks Mark Steyn think that's
right for being a Sherpa know that
twisted path yeah which we all need more
healing as Wendy it's more complicated
than it looks Tucker I'm for healing
thank you Mark